alors l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la motion de censure
déposée en application de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution par Monsieur
André chassen madame Mathilde Panau
cyriielle châelin et 110 membres de
l'Assemblée la première ministre ayant
engagé la responsabilité du Gouvernement
sur l'adoption en lecture définitive du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2023
à
2027 donc je vais donner la parole à
monsieur Jean-Victor castor pour le
groupe GDR pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général chers
collègues il me revient aujourd
aujourd'hui au nom du groupe de la
France insoumise du groupe écologiste et
du groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine de demander la censure du
gouvernement pour la 6e fois depuis le
mois de septembre et la 17e fois depuis
le début de la législature la première
ministre a décidé de recourir pour
l'adoption définitive du projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
aux dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la
Constitution par cet acte le
gouvernement a de nouveau fait le choix
de la brut
pour forcer l'adoption d'un texte qui ne
dispose pas d'une majorité à l'image de
son rejet en première lecture il y a 1
an ou de l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire depuis plus d'un an le dénis
démocratique est devenu la marque de
fabrique de ce gouvernement les 493 se
multiplient et à chaque fois la
brutalité
s'accroit ce gouvernement s'amuse d'un
jeu malsin et profondément
antidémocratique qui consiste à faire
peser le 493 comme une épé d'amoclesè
au-dessus du Parlement réduisant comme
pot de chagrin les débats dans
l'hémicycle vous refusez désormais toute
discussion qui pourrait démontrer votre
enfermement et votre isolement pour ce
texte vous avez même tenté un chantage
médiocre en laissant croire que sa
nonadoption amènerait l'Union européenne
à couper certains crédits budgétaires
prévu dans le cadre des plans nationaux
de relance et de résilience ce manque de
respect s'adresse bien entendu à nous
parlementaires qui ne pouvons exercer
notre principale fonction celle de faire
la loi que de travail effectué lors de
l'examen de ces projets de loi pour
faire des propositions porter ici à
l'Assemblée la voix de nos territoires
respectifs pour démontrer que d'autres
choix alternatifs sont possibles ce
travail de plusieurs semaines jeté à la
poubelle en quelques minutes est aussi
celui de tous nos collaborateurs et de
toutes les personnes qui œuvrent au
fonctionnement de cette institution mais
ce manque de respect que vous démontrez
s'adresse surtout aux millions de
Français qui nous ont élus en
multipliant l'adoption des texte sans
vote en refusant le débat contradictoire
vous alimentez inexorablement le Moulin
des ennemis de la
démocratie comment voulez-vous redonner
confiance au peuple par votre
utilisation abjecte des principes
constitutionnels vous en détournez les
valeurs car le travail parlementaire ne
se limite pas à quelques passes d'armes
entre ministres et députés dans
l'hémicycle pour chaque débat ce sont
des déplacements depuis nos
circonscription jusqu'à Paris pour
chaque texte pour chaque amendement ce
sont des dizaines de personnes qui
travaillent pour chaque séance ce sont
des personnels de l'Assemblée mobilisés
et des moyens de fonctionnement déployés
nous parlons ici de millions d'euros
nous parlons ici de millions d'euros en
déplacement hébergement cûp de
fonctionnement masse salariale un gouver
responsable et respectueux des
institutions aurait aussi pris cet
aspect en considération mais vous n'êtes
ni responsable ni respectueux des
institutions et vous osez vous osez
donner des leçons de sobriété au peuple
la démocratie n'a pas de prix quand elle
fonctionne le Parlement a une fonction
celle de
légiférer par votre utilisation dévoyé
des institutions en empêchant
législateur que nous sommes de faire ce
pourquoi nous avons été élus vous
daignez la démocratie et par voie de
conséquence vous favorisez le gaspillage
du bien public mais peut-être est-ce là
votre objectif inavouable au nom des
économies àouva supprimer le Parlement
puisque par l'usage abusif du 493 vous
ne cessez de vous en passer pourtant la
situation en France est de plus en plus
grave et la loi de programmation des
finances publiques loin d'être
anecdotique aurait mérité un débat
l'objectif des lois de programmation est
de fixer une trajectoire budgétaire pour
les années à venir une idée qui pourrait
être séduisante car elle se rapproche
d'une logique de planification de
l'économie mais en fixant des plafonds
de dépenses des plafonds d'emploi ou
encore des normes de dépenses elles
agissent aujourd'hui comme un carcan qui
ne vise qu'une seule chose détruire le
pacte social français qui s'appuie sur
la sécurité sociale et les services
publics nationaux et
locaux cette loi de programmation pour
les années 2023- 2027 est une des plus
éclairantes sur le sujet en fixant une
trajectoire budgétaire austéritaire dans
des proportions jamais atteintes
auparavant la croissance moyenne des
dépenses publiques qu'elle prévoit est
fixée à 0,1 %. et si on exclut l'exction
de certaines mesures temporaires en 2024
cette croissance atteindra 0,6 %. soit
une croissance encore plus faible que
celle mise en place durant la période
austéritaire qui a suivi la crise de
2008 et les attaques spéculative contre
certains États européens cependant les
futures économies moins 12 milliards à
partir de 2025 reste pour l'heur peu
documenté la question est donc simple
sur quel poste porteront les futures
économies serait sur la politique du
logement ù le choc d'offre un temps
promis n'a jamais eu lieu planB par les
pensctions opérées sur les bailleurs
serait sur le financement de l'hôpital
public ou de l'école des domaines qui
souffrent déjà de manque structurel de
moyens ù serait-ce enfin sur la baisse
encore et toujours de certaines aides ou
allocation à à l'image des proposes
ambigues du gouvernement sur la
suppression de l'aide médicale de l'état
la pauvreté ne cesse de croître tous les
inducateur l'indique 9 millions de
Français se trouvent en situation de
privation matérielle un/ers des Français
saent des repas et certains le font pour
permettre à leurs enfants de manger un
Français sur 5 déclare vivre à découvert
et près d'un Fran sur de est dans
l'incapacité totale ou partielle de
payer certains actes
médicaux le nombre de sans-abris a
doublé en 10 ans et le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire a
triplé les effets de l'appauvrissement
de la population sont comme à
l'accoutumé décuplé dans les pays dit
d'outrem en Guyane le taux de personnes
vivant sous le seuil de pauvreté a été
multiplié par 2 en 5 ans nos territoires
sont sinistré économiquement
sanitairement socialement mais cette loi
de programmation budgétaire au lieu de
travailler au mieux-être de la
population organise méthodiquement son
appauvrissement la situation sociale
tout comme les enjeux écologiques de ce
pays exige de nouvelles dépenses qui
s'avèrent noncciliables avec les
objectifs de ce texte et cette dépenses
nouvelles induisent nécessairement des
recettes nouvelles pour l'État ou pour
les collectivités
or ce texte enterre toute mesure en
terme de recette pour l'État et ce alors
même que le nombre de milliardaires et
leur patrimoine cumulé ne cessent de
croître le rapport sensu mati a ainsi
clairement mis en évidence une
concentration toujours plus importante
du capital et la construction
progressive d'une société de l'héritage
et de la rente cette situation ne pourra
être combatue que par l'instauration de
mesures fiscales nouvelles comme une
contribution exceptionnelle des hauts
patrimoinees à l'image des
préconisations d'économistes plutôt
libéraux comme Salma mafou ou Jean
pisanifé dans ces conditions le groupe
GDR ne peut que s'opposer à ce projet de
la loi de programmation des finances
publici qui fixe une trajectoire
budgétaire délétaire pour les 4 années à
venir un texte qui fait le choix de
réduire un peu plus encore le pacte
social français et refuse de demander à
tous nos concitoyens leur juste
participation face à l'entêement du
gouvernement à faire adopter ce texte de
manière autoritaire en ayant encore
recours au 493 je vous demande donc
aujourd'hui chers collègues de censurer
le
gouvernement merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur denim
Masseglia pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
messieurs et mesdames les ministres mes
chers
collègues l'échange de ce soir s'inscrit
à la suite de l'examen du projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 pour lequel
il a été fait recours à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de notre
Constitution rappelons tout d'abord aux
personnes qui nous regardent ce dont il
est question
ici un document de 72 pages qui présente
les orientations budgétaires de la
France pour chaque programme justice
éducation ou encore culture d'ici à
2027 à celles et ceux qui nous regardent
ce projet de loi soyons clair ne
permettra pas de remplir votre frigo de
trouver un médecin ou de faire garder
vos
ni de réduire les émissions de
CO2 ce projet de loi vise tout
simplement à présenter les orientations
pluriannuelles du budget de notre pays
avec pour ambition d'en réduire le
déficit pour
certains très à gauche et très bruyant
ce déficit n'est pas un
problème au contraire ce serait la
solution car rappelons qu'en 2022 votre
leader proposé 250 milliards d'euros de
dépenses
supplémentaires dépens qui selon lui
rapporterait 267
milliards selon les économistes de la
LFI donc plus de dépenses est égal à
moins de déficit étrange
calcul dans cette logique j'ai une
question qui me brûle les
lèvres pouro ne pas prévoir plus de
dépenses pour être soyons ambitieux
effacer carrément la
dette fort heureusement le projet de
programmation de loi des finances
publiques pour les années 2003 à 2027
tel que proposé par le Gouvernement
présente une trajectoire claire visant à
réduire notre
déficit c'est un projet de loi
responsable qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité de l'action menée par la
majorité présidentielle depuis 2017 7 je
je me permettrai d'ailleurs de vous
rappeler que c'est sous cette majorité
en 2018 que notre pays est sorti de la
procédure de déficit excessif lancé par
la Commission
européenne en 2020 nous avons été
frappés de plein fouet par la pandémie
de covid-19 qui a inévitablement marquer
un coup de frein à notre ambition de
réduire notre
déficit à ce moment-là
la priorité devait bien entendu aller
comme toujours à la protection de
l'emploi et des personnes les plus
fragiles mais cette fois-ci c'était à
raison quoi qu'il en
coûte que le député ou les députés qui
n'étaient pas favorable aux aides pour
nos boulangers ou nos resturateurs lève
la
main aujourd'hui cette période est
derrière nous il est impératif de
revenir à notre ambition initiale de
réduire notre
déficit maîtriser nos dépenses ce n'est
pas seulement faire preuve de
responsabilité
financière c'est également protéger
notre nation défendre notre
souveraineté et éviter et éviter que nos
enfants ne deviennent les créditeurs de
notre absence de
[Musique]
courage ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pose un constat très clair
en 2023 la dette nous coûte 38 milliards
d'euros en l'état des taux d'intérêt ce
coût serait de 74 milliards d'euros en
2027 deux points de taux supplémentaires
par rapport aux estimations porterait le
coût de la dette à plus de 100 milliards
d'euros imaginez donc ce qu'il en serait
si nous accep sans sourciller ce que
certains proposent
ici c'est sûr faire preuve de prudence
financière et de sérieux budgétaire
suscite beaucoup moins d'enthousiasme
que les propositions des deux extrémités
de cet hémicycle
elles ont en commun d'appeler
continuellement et inablement à de
nouvelles
dépenses finalement la seule différence
entre LFI et le RN porte sur le
financement de ses
dépenses pour la
première la France
irresponsable le financement
s'oppose le financement s'opère en
stigmatisant les personnes qui
réussissent et en supprimant les
riches pour le second le rejet national
le financement s'opère en stigmatisant
certains de nos concitoyens et en
supprimant
l'migration charmant
programme
voyez-vous chers collègues les attitudes
caricaturales de LFI et du RN me font
penser à l'œuvre de Jean de La
Fontaine 350 ans plus tard ces Faves
décrivent avec une grande justesse
certaines postures de cet
hémicycle nous avons à gauche la France
insoumise je propose la Cigale et la
fourmie la Alfiste ayant chanté tout
l'été se trouva fort dépourvu quand les
factures fut venues pas un seul petit
morceau de l'antiorail ou bio elle all
la crier famine chez la travailleuse sa
voisine la préant la priant de lui payer
quelques taxes pour subsister jusqu'à
l'élection
nouvelle les riches vous payeront lui
dit-elle avant l'out suivant mon idéal
l'intérêt est le
principal la travailleure n pas prêteuse
c'est là son moindre
défaut que
faisiez-vous que faisiez-vous quand le
chômage était au plus bas dit-elle à
cette
emprunteuse nuit et jour tout venant jus
de mon droit à loisiv ne vous
déplaise vous Glandier j'en suis for
manif
mainten blement
national le corbeau et le renard vous si
à
merveille maître électeur dans une
démocratie ébréchée tenez dans ses mains
un
suffrage maître Le Pen par l'odeur
àécher lui teint à peu près ce
langage bonjour monsieur l'é lecteur que
vous êtes joli que vous me semblez avoir
peur sans mentir vos difficultés c'est
la faute aux
immigrés vous êtes pourtant l' de ces
bois à ces mots l'électeur est pris
l'effroid et pour montrer son choix
ouvre sa main laisse tomber sa voix Le
Pen Le Pen s'en saisit et dit mon bon
monsieur apprenez que tout flatteur vit
au dépend de celui qui l'écoute
cette leçon vaut bien une attaque à la
démocratie sans doute l'é lecteur
honteux et confus Jura comme en 33 qu'on
ne lu reprendrait
plus loin de ces postur
car la majorité présidentielle travaille
avec responsabilité pour trouver un
équilibre complexe mais indispensable ou
nous devons continuer d'inv dans publ
dans les transitions écologiques et
numériques dans l'accompagnement des
plus fragiles et oui s'il vous
plaît vous laissez terminer son discours
vous FZ un rappel au règlement
ultérieurement allez-y monsieur
l'orateurz
[Applaudissements]
oui je je viens de vous dire que je
l'avais enregistré il
termine son
propos
allez-y monsieur Masseglia merci madame
la Présidente finalement la caricature
est présente au quotidien dans
l'hémicycle loin de ces postures
caricaturales la majorité présidentielle
travaille avec responsabilité pour
trouver un équilibre complexe mais
indispensable oui nous devons continuer
d'investir dans nos services publics
dans la dans les transitions écologiques
et numérique dans l'accompagnement des
plus fragiles et oui cela n'est pas
incompatible avec le fait de contenir
nos
dépenses dans dans cette perspective
nous trouvons à nos côté un gouvernement
imprégé par ce devoir Premier ministre
ministre de l'Économie ministre des
finances sont chacun à saluer pour leur
engagement leur ténacité et leur
travail ce travail en responsabilité
justement est reconnu jusqu'audelà de
nos frontières preuve en est le maintien
de la donn à la France notre objectif
n'est pas ici de faire plaisir au aux
agences de notation notre
objectif il est tout simplement dev vrai
pour assurer le financement de notre
dette et donc de notre
avenir viser l'objectif de faire passer
notre déficit public sous la fameuse
barre des 3 % ce n'est pas utopiste Sion
s'en tient à ce travail en
responsabilité objectif n'est pas de
faire plaisir à l'Union européenne mais
simplement devrait pour assurer le
financement de notre dette et donc de
notre
souveraineté faute de travail en
responsabilité nous risquons de voir
notre taux d'emprunt augmenter fortement
ce qui implique le risque de devoir
réaliser des choix compliqués qui auront
de lourdes conséquences pour les
Français vis-à-vis de devons être clair
quant à nos
priorités nos priités ce sont les
réponses que nous devons apporter aux
défis et aux urgences de ce siècle les
grandes transitions sont re autre
d'ordre écologique numérique ou encore
démographique c'est là que nous devons
concentrer notre énergie notre temps
notre responsabilité je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègu alors je prends le rappel au
règlement allez-y mon cher
collègue attends oui madame la
Présidente sur la base de l'article 70-3
effet personnel monsieur massegli a
quand même il a le droit de faire des
effets de manches dans c'était très
drôle c'est ça ça c'est ces énoncés de
de de fable de La Fontaine c'est c'est
très drôle et et c'est on peut accepter
tout mais quand il termine sa phrase en
disant comme en 33 c'est un c'est une
réduction aditler qui était inadmissible
dans cette assemblée on ne peut pas
comparer un groupe de députés à ce qui
s'est passé en Allemagne en 1933 c'est
totalement inadmissible et je demande
donc qu'il y a un rappel à l'ordre de
Masseglia avec inscription à l'ordre du
jour parce que c'est vraiment on ne peut
pas aujourd'hui dans la situation du
pays avec ce qui s'est passé depuis 2
mois dans le monde entier et tout ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en France et le moi
enfin je n'étais pas présent hier dans
cette projection de film mais ramener un
GR groupe de députés à l'Allemagne Nazi
c'est quand même
inadmissible bon écoutez je me fais
communiquer le texte exact pour regarder
quels ont été les propos qui ont été
prononcés et j'aviserai oui mais il faut
que j'ai la phrase d'avant et la phrase
d'après c'est quand même mieux pour
regarder le contexte alors Monsieur
Aurélien Lopez luigori pour le
rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
h madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues nous y
sommes donc le 17e 493 en 18 mois
d'exercice cela en devient presque
monotone la première ministre est
visiblement du même avis car elle ne
digne même plus annoncer elle-même les
passages en force devant la
représentation nationale et envoie des
ministres subalternes les notifi à sa
place
quelle sera la prochaine
humiliation quel est ce pouvoir qui ne
fait même plus semblant d'écouter de
chercher le compromis de respecter
l'équilibre des institutions quel est ce
gouvernement qui certain de n'avoir
jamais tort en perd la raison au rythme
où les 49 300 chînes il ne faudra encore
qu'une seule année pour que Madame borne
ou son successeur battent le triste
record de Michel Rocard mais monsieur
Rocard même monsieur Rocard attendait la
fin des débats parlementaires avant de
passer en force devant les députés car
il tenait à s'assurer que toute
négociation était impossible avant
d'imposer la
force désormais le gouvernement ne s'en
donne même plus la peine les débat n'ont
même plus lieu avec la macronie le
contournement des représentants du
peuple devient normal le mépris de la
démocratie une habitude le refus du
dialogue la
règle pourtant le lors des dernières
élections législatives les Français
avaient justement refusé de vous donner
une majorité absolue pour que vous
coconstruisiez avec les oppositions pour
que vous essayez de trouver des
positions qui nous rassemblent et
aujourd'hui vous faites tout l'inverse
vous préférez vous terrer derrière vos
passages en force qui vous donneent une
illusion de toutepuissance vous agissez
ainsi parce que vous savez que vous êtes
incapable de rassembler le pays autour
d'un projet
fédérateur et pour cause et pour cause
qui à part cette majorité relative
caporalisée pouritcautionner vos actes
qui pourrait suivre votre aile acharnée
à promouvoir la tirmondisation de notre
pays cette loi de programmation des
finances publicque 2023-2027 que vous
adoptez contre la majorité de
l'Assemblée nationale en est la preuve
supplémentaire pour ne pas déplaire à
bruxel il faudra que les Français
continuent à faire des efforts mais sur
quoi que leur reste-t-il
sur le plan social quelle dépenses
reste-t-il à Rogier le gouvernement a
déjà fait passer sa réforme des
retraites en reculant l'âge de départ à
64 ans il a déjà diminué les droits des
chômeurs il a déjà coupé les dépenses de
sa politique de logement tandis qu'il
multiplie les cadeaux fiscaux aux plus
riches depuis
2017 sur le plan des services publics
que peut-on Rogier dans des structures
qui sont déjà à l'os les hôpitaux
fonctionnent déjà à flux tendu et les
déserts médicaux
s'élargissent les enseignements de
l'éducation nationale sont déjà démunis
face à des classes de plus en plus
nombreuses tandis que le niveau général
d'instruction
s'effondre sur le plan du pouvoir
d'achat des Français l'inflation grève
tous les budgets des ménages si bien que
se chauffer l'hiver ou prendre sa
voiture dans les zones rurales est
devenu un
luxe sur le plan sécuritaire les
commissariats et les casanes sont déjà
exang nos policiers et nos gendarmes
risquent chaque jour leur vie pour moins
de 2000 € par mois tandis que ça croit
l'ensauvagement de la société française
alimenté par l'immigration de masse et
les défaillances de notre système
judiciaire l'épisode des émeutes
urbaines de l'été dernier en a été le
résultat très concret si l'on continue
d'abandonner nos forces de l'ordre ces
explosions de violence amplifieront en
nombre et en gravité jusqu'à
l'irrémédiable
surtous les plans les voyants sont au
rouge l'état stratège et protecteur
s'effondre vous emmenez la France droit
dans le mur et tout cela pour être le
bon élève de Bruxelles tout cela car
vous avez peur de ne pas être
parfaitement aligné sur les objectifs
budgétaires fixés par la Commission
européenne qu'est-il arrivriver à la
souveraineté française pour que nous
craignions à ce point que l'Union
européenne nous confisse que notre
propre argent car je vous rappelle que
la France est contributrice nette au
budget de l'Union
européenne dans cette histoire les
Français sont les créanciers pas les déb
débiteurs à partir du moment où cet
argent est le notre nous avons toutes
les marges de manœuvre à condition d'en
avoir la volonté alors arrêtez avec ce
chantage indigne cessez de prendre les
Français en otage et assumer vos
responsabilités au rassemblement
national avec Marine Le Pen notre ligne
d'action se résume à un objectif très
clair rendre aux Français leur pays
rendre aux Français leur argent a mis le
lieu de ce principe de bon sens le
gouvernement et sa majorité relative
préfère imposer au députés une loi
attentatoire à notre souveraineté
budgétaire notre pays agonise d'être
conduit par des chefs sans vision
balloté au gré des événements qui qui se
raccroche désespérément aux jupes de
Madame Van derleyen pour trouver un cap
et face au piétitement de notre
démocratie et de nots souveraineté
qu'avons-nous le sketch habituel de la
gauche qu'elle répète stérilement à
chaque pachas en force du gouvernement
la nuupesse ou ce qu'il en reste c'est
un état permanent de guerre de tous
contre tous une opposition qui s'oppose
à elle-même et qui s'étant épuisé toute
seule finit complètement
marginalisée au milieu de cette
cacophonie plus rien de cohérent ne
ressort si ce n'est des motions de
censure que même ses alliés ne votent
plus et dont les consignataires sont de
moins en moins nombreux à chaque texte
et oui et oui vous en avez 110 ou 120 au
lieu de 160 à chaque texte la gauche
dépose des motions deens de rejet à
chaque 493 des motions de censure leur
caractère solennel en est totalement
dénaturé le principe d'opposition
parlementaire en évité en évidé de sa
substance par le fait d'agitateur public
en mal de reconnaissance par des députés
prêtes à tout pour leur peties vidéos
sur les
réseaux la droite est également
activement coupable la question les
intéresse tellement qu'ils sont
systématiquement pas plus de deux ou
trois dans l'hémicycl quand il s'agit de
voter des motions de censure même
lorsque celles-ci ont un sens et un
espoir d'aboutir c'est d'ailleurs la
spécialité des républicains alors du
républicains aujourd'hui puisqu'on en a
qu'un seul de tou voir se targer du
courage des mots à défaut d'avoir celui
des actes le rassemblement national ne
participera pas à ces agitations
incohérentes ne voterons pas donc cette
motion de censure les députés RN ont
répondu présent dès le début de l'examen
du texte pour dénoncer l'arnaque que
représente ce projet de loi nous avons
voté contre le texte en première lecture
nous avons proposé des amendement nous
avons même voté la motion de censure de
l'anupes en seconde lecture après un 493
mais nous ne nous enfoncerons pas dans
cette opposition stérile et tragicocique
que vous qui vous définit d'ailleurs
tellement bien d'ailleurs les Français
le savent nous avons prouvé notre
engagement le long du processus
législatif pour tout faire pour contrer
ce projet de loi des les TER et nous
continuerons à peser dans le processus
législatif jusqu'au jour où les Français
vous éjecteront de cet
hémicycle madame la Première ministre en
dégainant 493 après 493 vous PZ pouvoir
vous abriter derrière la Constitution
mais n'oubliez jamais que ces armes ont
toujours un coup démocratique et qu'à
chaque fois que vous enusez c'est votre
crédit et votre légitimité qui part en
fumé en recourant au 493 sur cette loi
de programmation des finances publiques
vous avez épuisé votre dernier joker
pour les mois à venir vous avez violé
une fois encore la démocratie et si vous
recommencez à l'occasion du projet de lo
sur l'immigration vous violerez la
Constitution
Max Weber explique qu'il y a de péchés
capitaux en politique ne défendre aucune
cause et n'avoir pas le sentiment de
responsabilité vous êtes précisément
coupable de l'un et de l'autre le temps
vous est compté la sanction des urne
approche et elle vous sera extrêmement
sévère je vous
merci la parole est à Madame Maranne
Maxim pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
collègues est-ce que le pouvoir
législatif existe encore dans notre
pays ce lundi l'exécutif a une nouvelle
fois ptiné l'Assemblée nationale sur la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour votre 17e 493 vous n'avez
même pas pris la peine de vous rendre
disponible madame borne la macronie
continue de disrupter sur la démocratie
et invente le 493 par
procuration lundi donc le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement tout un
symbole tout de même est venu porter à
notre connaissance une lettre de votre
main qui annonce un nouveau passage en
force au bout de
17493 on doit au moins reconnaître que
le gouvernement a optimisé l'exercice 3
minutes et 4 secondes après l'ouverture
de la séance le débat était clos bouclé
et verrouillé un nouveau record
d'efficacité qui doit vous rendre fier
j'en suis sûr ce 493 est aussi inédit
car vous avez multiplié les rus pour
pouvoir l'utiliser la programmation des
finances publiques n'est pas un texte
budgétaire alors vous avez convoqué une
excession extraordinaire en septembre
pour disposer d'un 493 pourquoi se
priver et quand le texte est revenu en
session ordinaire vous avez prétendu que
vous pouviez utiliser sans compter un
nouveau 493 au motif qu'il aurait été
déjà activé un drôle de procédé dont la
constitutionnalité est questionnée par
plusieurs juristes et sur lesquelles
nous ne manquerons pas de nous pencher
alors si vous innovez sur la forme le
fond est malheureusement toujours le
même et toujours aussi décevant pour
justifier ce nouveau passage en force
vous nous rejouez le la carte des débats
ont été longs de l'absence de majorité
alternative que ce texte serait au
combien indispensable pour relever les
grands défis à venir et assurer notre
crédibilité mais tout cela n'est qu'une
comédie ponctuée de grand blabla et au
bout d'un an et demi ces arguments ne
tiennent plus d'abord parce que nous
avons démontré lors du débat budgétaire
à l'Assemblée nationale qu'on était
capable de dégager des majorités
simplement ces dernières ne plaisent pas
au président de la République Emmanuel
Macron
à plusieurs reprises contre l'avis du
gouvernement nous avons fait adopter des
amendements budgétaires les 20 milliards
d'euros de recettees fiscales en plus
voté par la commission des finances
effacé par le 493 la hausse des
rémunérations des salariés de l'aide à
domiciles des des aesh le maintien de la
civise retiré par le 493 les 1,5
milliards pour le frais de ferroviaire
les 100 millions pour le fond de soutien
au développement des MJC et associations
culturelles dans les quartiers
populaires balayé
493 ensuite vous ne dites que cette loi
est une nécessité mais ce n'est pas vrai
c'est même parfaitement le contraire
cette loi elle est dangereuse pour les
finances publiques elle nous fait
sombrer pour les quatre prochaines
années dans un dans une abîme pardon
austéritaire vous refusez le terme
austérité mais comment appelez-vous une
loi qui impose aux dépenses publiques
d'évoluer vers moins vite que
l'inflation comment appelez-vous une loi
qui limite les créations d'emplois dans
les ministères dans les opérateurs de
l'État comment appelez-vous une loi dont
la seule boussole est la réduction de la
dette et du déficit public quoi qu'il en
coûte pour nos services
publics les dépenses publiques sont
créatrices de richesse ce n'est pas de
l'argent qu'on jette par les fenêtres et
qui disparaîtrait dans la nature coupé
ainsi à l'aveugle ne fera qu'apppauvrir
l'état cette loi elle est tellement
austéritaire que vous allez réellement
appauvrir l'État et on grince des dents
quand on pense qu'il y a quelques mois
Emmanuel Macron au français par 493 pour
changer de travailler 2 ans de plus au
prétexte que l'argent manquait pour
financer nos
[Applaudissements]
retraites tout cela n'assurant rien
notre crédibilité c'est même le
contraire cette logique économique est à
contesens de notre époque elle est
complètement en décalage avec les enjeux
qui traversent notre pays comment
espérer respecter l'accord de Paris
quand nous devons investir entre 60 et
70 milliards d'euros par an plus vous
attendez pour réaliser ces
investissements plus plus la facture
écologique va augmenter en 2022 rien que
les catastrophes naturelles sans parler
de tous les autres effets du dérèglement
climatique ça nous a déjà coûté 10
milliards d'euros à la puissance
publique pour répondre à la crise
sociale qui secoue notre pays il
faudrait investir dans les services
publics de proximité dans le logement
dans l'école dans la santé il faudrait
par exemple investir pour que chaque
élève en situation d'handicap puiss
aller à l'école pour cela il n'y a pas
assez d'AES aujourd'hui en raison de V
politique d'économie de bout de
chandelle il en manque des milliers et
rien que dans mon département le pu D'Ô
ce sont 200 élèves qui sont privés de
scolarité il faudrait investir pour que
les femmes puissent accoucher en
sécurité près de chez elles dans des
maternités qui fonctionnent il faudrait
s'assurer que les malades puissent se
faire soigner où qu'ils vivent une
nécessité absolue alors que les
mobilisations se multiplient contre les
fermetures de services d'urgence et que
le personnel hospitalier sera en grève
demain pour dénoncer l'affaiblissement
du système de
santé il faudrait des trains qui
fonctionnent des logements abordables un
accompagnement social pour les familles
en difficultés éducativ des lieux de
placements pour les enfants en danger il
faudrait que les citoyens puissent
manger à leur faim que les familles à la
rue et les enfants à la rue soient
relogés rapidement
immédiatement et c'est de tout cela que
nous prive ce texte en nous fixant un
objectif d'austérité pour les prochaines
années même les collectivité
territoriale payent le prix de vos
obsessions budgétaires elle se voit
contrainte alors qu'elle d'alerter sur
l'état de leurs finances et plutôt que
de les aider afin de pour financer à la
hauteur leurs compétences et les tâches
que l'État leur confie elles voient
elles aussi leurs dépenses plafonnées en
dessous de
l'inflation j'alerte ici les ministres
et mes collègu abuser du 493 pour un un
projet politique sans majorité
parlementaire le gouvernement est en
train de dissoudre le pouvoir
législatif les passages en force
successives vident le sens de notre
travail et notre fonction à quoi bon
pour les citoyens de ne solliciter si à
la fin Emmanuel Macron décide seul à
quoi bon pour les associations les
syndicats de proposer des solutions si à
la fin tous les amendements sont balayés
par un
493 à force de priver l'Assemblée
nationale de vote mais aussi de débat
l'exécutif est en train de faire
disparaître le pouvoir législatif et
d'anesthésier la vie politique cette
façon de gouverner est en train de créer
des impasses démocratiques grave elles
vont augmenter le sentiment
antiparlementaire elles vont surtout
créer des durable entre les citoyens et
la vie démocratique de notre pays car
votre autoritarisme déborde les murs de
notre assemblée il s'exprime sous de
multiples formes alors un ministre de la
Justice mis en examen bah il reste en
poste une association écologiste se
mobilise contre les mégabassines on la
dissou enfin on essaie de la dissoudre
car pour une fois le Conseil d'État a
joué son rôle de gardefou et annuler
votre honteuse
décision de la peinture sur les murs
d'un ministère tout le monde en garde à
vue une mobilisation contre un projet
routier tout le monde en garde à vue les
enfants des quartiers qui se révoltent
en garde à vue et en prison les
manifestations pour la paix on les
interdit on arrête tout le monde pour
une pancarte ou un drapeau votre pouvoir
ne tient plus qu'à quelques fils à la
complaisance de la droite qui s'efforce
d'être à votre remorque sera peut-être
d'ailleurs le prochain groupe de la
majorité relative ça tient aussi aux
négociations avec l'extrême droite qui
on le rappelle a tenté de monayer son
abstention sur ce texte en nous
déroulant pourtant son discours contre
l'austérité venue de Bruxelles mais en
fait vous êtes pas une incohérence prês
mais votre majorité se relative se
fissure aussi et nombreux dans vos rant
désapprouvent cette débauche de passage
en force dans quelques jours la macronie
ira chercher sur les bancs de LR et du
RN une majorité pour faire voter son
texte sur la sur l'immigration ce qui
ajoutera encore de la confusion et de la
pagaille à moins que là encore vous ne
préf préférez un car
93 en fait ce n'est qu'une question de
temps pour que tout l'édifice s'écroule
le problème c'est que votre dérive
autoritaire peut entraîner bien plus que
la macronie avec elle ce qui est menacé
par les par ces passages en force c'est
l'espoir de la politique l'espoir dans
notre capacité collective à faire
changer les choses et la responsabilité
de la gauche de l'anupes elle est
précisément là de faire vivre cette
alternative et d'incarner avec
crédibilité c'est cette façon que nous
de cette façon que nous ferons reculer
le désespoir créé par la macronie sur
lequel l'extrême droite pospère et
j'appelle donc toutes les forces
progressistes qui chaisent dans cet
hémicycle à s'opposer à l'autoritarisme
d'Emmanuel Macron et à défendre la
démocratie en votant cette motion de
censure merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Marie-Christine dalallose pour les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
voici de nouveau réunis ce soir pour
débattre d'une 1è motion de censure
déposée par le la présidente Panau et
ses collègues de la France
insoumise on est tellement habitué à ce
ce soit
fille une
réaction une réaction
systématique aussi mécanique que veine
suite au déclenchement du du 19e du 17e
493 lundi dernier
17e sur le projet de loi de
programmation révisé des finances
publiques pour les années 2023
2027 la banalisation de l'exceptionnel
ainsi va laave parlementaire sous cette
majorité présidentielle relative mais
les manœuvres politiciennes de la France
insoumise ne sauraient nous faire
oublier les essentiel l'adoption
définitive ce soir d'une trajectoire
budgétaire peu ambitieuse qui acte le
renoncement définitif du gouvernement à
redresser nos comptes publics madame la
Première ministre vous avez attendu près
d'un an pour nous soumettre de nouveau
un projet et la déception est au
rendez-vous pourtant les ajouts du Sénat
traduisaient une volonté politique
réelle d'en finir avec le désolant
triptique français des 3D dette déficit
dépenses ah oui c'est la réalité en
refusant de prendre les responsabilités
qui devraient être les vôtres vous
engagez durablement la France dans la
spirale de
l'endettement plus de 3000 milliards
d'euros de dettte on peut en sourire mes
chers collègues on peut on peut le
contester mais c'est une
réalité plus de 3000 milliards d'euros
de dettes désormais 285 milliards
d'euros empruntés sur les marchés
financiers en 2024 une charge de la
dette évaluée à 57 milliards d'euros dès
2024 certes la copie est un peu
meilleure je l'admets madame la Première
ministre la copie est un peu meilleure
que lors du premier dépôt de cette loi
puisque l'effort demandé à l'état est
réhaussé de plus vous abandonnez le
pacte de chaor ou la succession et enfin
la pente est moins injuste pour les
collectivités mais madame la Première
ministre soyons honnête nous sommes
encore très loin du compte tous les
signaux budgétaires sont au rouge la
situation est plus alarmante que jamais
et vos remèdes sont au mieux
homéopathiques le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques dresse lui-même l'IMP
l'implacable constat que la trajectoire
retenue ne prévoit pas de retour rapide
vers l'objectif d'équilibre des finances
publiques prenez acte pas vous madame la
Première ministre un de vos un député de
votre groupe de nombreuses mesures
structurelles économie vous ont pourtant
été proposé par les républicains pour un
total de 25 milliards d'euros dans le
cadre de contrebudget en soutien au
pouvoir d'achat des Français à la
famille en faveur de la revalorisation
du travail et d'une correction des
dispositifs de soins aux étrangers et de
l'amélioration des procédures de soins
un projet ambitieux qui permettrait de
baisser les les prélèvement obligatoire
de 10,8 milliards d'euros de
redistribuer 2,4 et de diminuer le
déficit à hauteur de 12 milliards
balayés d'un revers de la main la cible
du désendettement est donc une nouvelle
fois manqué alors que la France figure
dans le quinté des pays les plus
endettés d'Europe et que nous serons le
dernier pays de la zone euro à revenir
sous la barre des 3 % de déficit en 2027
c'est un triste constat à toutes fins
utiles je vous rappelle que la
Commission européenne a annoncé lever la
clause générale dérogatoire à la fin de
cette année voilà la réalité c'est que
votre manque de courage politique pèse
sur les Français qui n'en finissent pas
de payer pour la 17e fois vous devez
donc vous résoudre à passer en force en
faisant abstraction du débat
parlementaire il n'en demeure pas moins
que l'absence de vote de la
représentation nationale privera de
solennité les engagements financiers
souscrits par la France auprès des
autorités
européennes il y a cependant il n a
cependant aucun suspense entretenir sur
le fait que le les députés du groupe les
républicains feront preuve de
responsabilité en ne votant pas la
motion de censure de ce soir bien que
nous déplorons ce recours massif au 493
qui abîme l'équilibre de nos
institutions démocratiques nous nous
faisons un devoir de rester une
opposition responsable nous devons nous
doter de cette outil budgétaire cadre
pour respecter la lettre de notre
Constitution une constitution don les
termes sont de plus en plus baffoués et
détourné au moyen d'une démagogie
toujours plus grossière ainsi dans les
rend de la France insoumise on s'indigne
que la démocratie soit je cite plus que
jamais humiliée mais mes chers collègues
qui humilie notre démocratie pas plus
tard que ce soir en estimant que nous
pourrions vous suivre dans votre
politique du pire vous déplorez
également que le
gouvern gouvernement refuse aux élus de
la nation le droit de débattre j'ai une
voix qui porte fort vous pouvez hurler
je vais monter mais qui paralyse qui
paralyse le fonctionnement de notre
assemblée texte après texte par le dépôt
compulsif de milliers d'amendements
thématiques et
identique qui a consommé l'intégralité
des crédits de la mission outremaire du
budget 2024 dans une outrance
d'amendement forçant l'interruption de
l'examen de la mission en commission des
finances privant ainsi les autres
groupes de défendre leurs amendements
restants mes chers collègu vous sieiez
la branche sur laquelle vous êtes assis
et aucune crédibilité ne peut être
laissée à vos arguments vous empêchez la
représentation nationale de s'exprimer
comme elle le devrait et vous
décrédibilisez son rôle auprès des
Français dans le seul et unique but
d'attirer l'attention sur
vous pire encore par ses agissements
vous confortez le gouvernement dans son
entreprise de musulman du Parlement une
telle attitude est dangereuse en
dévitalisant la vie de l'Assemblée
nationale en vidant d'un trait de plume
des semaines entières de calendrier
parlementaire en démobilisant les
députés vous alimentez les leurs
frustrations vous crispez les Français
et vous souffler sur les braises de la
colère je n'ai pas peur de le dire vous
portez mesdames et messieurs les députés
de laanupes une grande en grande partie
la responsabilité de ce déluge de
493 rendez-vous
compte aucun amendement sur la partie
recette du projet de loi de finance pour
2024 n'aura été débattu en séance
publique c'est du jamais vu et c'est
votre
responsabilité de nombreux sujets
essentiels non AINS pas pu être abordé
la crise du logement la réforme de la
CVAE les crédits ma prime rinov dont
nous avons découvert il y a quelques
jours une sous-exécution majeure
conduisante à une annulation de crédit
de 1,1 milliard d'euros mais apparemment
ça ne vous concernait pas la démocratie
est bien plus perdante de votre
stratégie
d'hystérisation du débat public c'est la
grande perdante de votre
hisystérisation mesdames et messieurs
les députés de LFI l'outrance l'outrance
n'a jamais fait la consistance politique
vous avez sauter à pied joint dans tous
les pièges tendus par le gouvernement
qui participe je le regrette à ce jeu de
dupe la motion de censure en ressort
banalisé vidé de sa substance originelle
les Français nous regardent mes chers
collègues faire de leur détresse votre
fond de commerce ne vous grandira pas et
ne grandira personne au contraire c'est
un affaissement un affaiblissement du
Parlement et donc de la démocratie je
déplore enfin le rôle du nation qui dans
une alliance de circonstan s'associe
quelquefois à votre
errance soutien que vous acceptez
derrière une apparente hostilité sans
rechigner et dans le plus grand silence
en ne votant pas votre motion de censure
les députés des républicains ne donnant
pas un blanc sain au gouvernement nous
refusons tout simplement de porter la
responsabilité d'un jeu dangereux qui
menace plus que jamais notre démocratie
je vous remercie merci
beaucoup merci
beaucoup allez un peu de silence s'il
vous plaît Monsieur Mohamed lakila pour
le groupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
démocrate
madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers
collègues voilà qu'on y retourne
certains avec panage je dirais avec un
petit Panach prêt pour un nouveau
chapitre palpitant de la saga motion de
censure votre saga présenté par les TR
troupe intrépide de la
nupess sauf le PS qui croisant les
doigts a peut-être enfin recalibré sa
boussole européenne depuis fin septembre
je m'en
félicite chers collègues vous excéz dans
l'art du Roget mais question consensus
c'est le désert total quelle alternative
proposez-vous à part votre désaccord
parfaitement
chorégraphié d'un côté on nous accuse
d'orchestrer une austérité digne d'
régime draconien et de l'autre on nous
reproche une molesse coupable dans le
redressement de nos comptes allez
comprendre permettez-moi d'éclairer ceux
qui à gauche crient à l'austérité il est
facile de défendre l'idée que le danger
d'un endettement excessif est virtuel
qui n'engage aucune conséquence sur la
vie quotidienne des Français mensonge je
vous pose une question face au danger de
l'endettement excessif croissant
devrions-nous rester les bras croisés en
se racontant des comptes pour enfants
c'est une
question les faits parlent d'eux même au
cours de la semaine dernière nous avons
voté dans cet hémicycle l'ouverture de
3,8 milliards d'euros de crédit
supplémentairire au titre de la charge
de la dette en raison de l'inflation et
de la hausse des taux d'intérêt à court
terme nous aurions préférer qu'elle
servent d'abord à financer le
renforcement de notre action en faveur
de la trans écologique ou encore l'école
mais la réalité de l'environnement
économique actuel ns contraint à les
rediriger vers le financement d'une
charge de la dette qui augmente chaque
année dangereusement car rappelons-le
chers collègues chaque euro dépensé pour
payer les intérêts de la dette est 1 €
en moins pour améliorer le cadre de vie
de nos
concitoyens je vous le dis ici comme je
le pense si nous ne voulons pas que la
charge de la dette ne devient notre
premier poste de dépenses en 2027 alors
il faut agir agir vite et fixer une
trajectoire de réduction des déficits et
de la
dette ne nous y trompons pas en parlant
d'austérité laanupè voudrait faire
croire aux Français que maîtrise des
dépenses publiques riment avec fin de
l'investissement comment pouvez-vous
chers collègues laisser planer de tels
sous-entendus ou alors même ce projet de
loi prévoit une Haus de dépens de
l'investissement de 40 % sur la période
pour permettre de financer les efforts
en faveur de la transition écologique
l'amélioration de notre système scolaire
ou encore la modernisation de nos armées
dans un second temps je souhaiteraiis
répondre à nos collègue
LR qui affirme que ce texte manque
d'ambition sans objectif de réduction de
notre dette et de nos déficits public la
trajectoire qui nous a été proposée est
atteignable et plus ambitieuse que dans
le texte initiale la dynamique de
désendettement nous ramènera à 108,1 %
de dett publiqu en 2027 au lieu des
110,9 prévus dans le texte présenté en
septembre 2022 ce qui aurait pourtant dû
satisfaire nos collègues les
républicains autre preuve s'il en
fallait une en octobre dernier modif
fich eux-mêmes ont maintenu la note de
la France l'histoire nous montre qu'il
faut réduire le déficit public
progressivement et graduellement pour ne
pas casser la croissance l'analyse de la
politique économique menée dans notre
pays au cours de la période 2010 2014
est en ce sens très riche d'enseignement
en raison de la crise des dettes
souveraines la France avait alors
procédé à un rééquilibrage budgétaire
extrêmement important notamment par
d'importantes Hauses des prélèvements
obligatoires pour les entreprises et
surtout les ménages réduisant un néant
la timide reprise de l'économie
européenne et renforçant la crise avec
avec des conséquences désastreuses pour
nos finances publiques nous ne voulons
pas répéter ces mêmes erreurs et nous
restons convaincus qu'une trajectoire de
réduction des déficits trop brutal telle
que proposé au Sénat mettrait en péril
tous nos efforts qui ont permis à notre
économie de rebondir rapidement et
d'aborder l'avenir avec confiance après
les crises successives de ces dernières
années enfin j'opposerai au soi-disant
manque d'ambition le fait qu'au-delà de
nous donner une trajectoire
une crédibilité cette loi de
programmation nous dote de dispositifs
adéquat pour contenir l'évolution de la
dépense et de la dette publique que ce
soit par une évaluation plus poussée un
dispositif de limitation dans le temps
des dépenses fiscales et des aides aux
entreprises ou encore pour mieux faire
face à la dette climatique une
trajectoire claire une baisse de
dépenses brune face à deux visions
complètement contradictoires et
foncièrement irréconciliable un seul
point aurait pu faire consensus celui de
la crédibilité nécessaire que nous
devons au français et à nos partenaires
européens par l'adoption de ce texte il
n'est pas imaginable qu'un pays comme le
nôtre ne puissent pas présenter au
français une projection sur l'avenir de
l'utilisation de ces denniers publics
nous le devons aussi car dans une
logique de responsabilité budgétaire
européenne que nous partageons le
versement des prochains paiements du
plan nationale de relance et de
résilience par la Commission européenne
est conditionné à l'adoption d'une loi
de programmation il s'agit d'une somme
totale de 18 milliards d'euros qui
doivent nous permettre de nous aider à
bâtir l'avenir de notre pays nous avons
longuement échangé au sujet du
conditionnement des versements européens
au cours de l'examen de ce texte afin de
lever tout doute à ce sujet notre
excellent rapporteur général et nous le
remercions à demandé des éléments de
précision notre ministre Bruno Le Maire
les éléments qui nous ont été
communiqués à la suite de cette demande
ne laissent aucun aucune place au doute
la Commission européenne a confirmé
formellement cette condition dans deux
courriers adressés aux autorités
françaises les 6 et 21 septembre dernier
dans de telles conditions dénoncer un
soi-disant grand chantage qui se ferait
qui serait fait au parlementaires dans
le casadre de l'examen de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques est
tout à fait scandaleux et c'est irres
je voudrais rétablir la
vérité la vérité le grand chantage vous
le faites au français en tenant de tel
discours au prétexte que vous avez
souhaité transformer ce texte en
référendum ou contre la politique
économique de cette majorité en faisant
appel et des arguments profement
europhobes vous vous estimez en droit de
priver les Français de 18 milliards qui
leur reviennent ce comportement est
profondément responsable dans ces
conditions quand les oppositions
irréconciliables s'enferment dans de
telles postures politique sur un texte
qui revet pourtant les enjeux capitaux
pour l'avenir de notre pays le sens des
responsabilités s'impose pour préserver
notre souveraineté notre crédibilité et
notre économie la première ministre a
engagé la responsabilité de son
gouvernement sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques que nous
soutenons
vous l'aurez compris chers collègues le
groupe démocrate ne votera donc pas la
motion de
censure merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Valérie
Rabo pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
socialiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ce soir
nous abordons donc la 17e motion de
censure du gouvernement après un nouveau
493 que vous avez déclenché alors
beaucoup a été dit au gré des différents
493 mais il faut quand même reconnaître
que ce 493 a malgré tout un caractère
singulier puisqu'il porte sur le projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour les années 2023 à 2027
qui a été rejeté par un vote souverain à
l'Assemblée nationale le 25 octobre 2022
alors on aurit pu imaginer que vous
reveniez avec un texte nouveau que vous
auriez entendu le fait qu'il y a eu un
vote contre le 25 octobre 2022 il n' a
rien été et vous revenez avec exactement
le même texte que vous soumettez à ce
493 autre constatation lorsque vous
déclenchez des 493 sur les lois de
finances vous nous dites alors nous nous
ne sommes pas d'accord mais vous
invoquez l'urgence vous invoquez la
nécessité de pouvoir disposer de crédits
budgétaires pour assurer la marche du
pays pour une noi programmation des
finances publiques aucun de ces
arguments ne peut être utilisé il n'y a
ni urgence ni nécessité car une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
fixe des perspectives et n'est pas un
outil pour débloquer des crédits
budgétaires aussi actionner le 493 sur
une loi de program des finances
publiques nous laisse entendre que vous
ne souhaitez nullement chercher un
consensus ce qui pourrait être sur le
diagnostic partagé de la situation et
que vous ne souhaitez pas non plus
responsabiliser chacun sur la
trajectoire future de nos finances
publiques je le dis avec gravité avec
sincérité d'autant plus que dès avril
2020 mon groupe parlementaire a
sollicité auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances la tenue
d'une conférence de financement sur la
pandémie et c'est une fin non recevoir
que nous avons reçu alors oui face à
cette situation je le dis d'emblé le
groupe socialiste est apparenté votera
la censure de votre gouvernement qui n'a
aucun droit à préempter l'avenir de
notre pays puisque vous ne voulez pas
associer l'Assemblée nationale à
l'exercice d'une loi de programmation
des finances publiques je vous proposer
que nous commencions cet exercice
ensemble madame la Première ministre
depuis cette tribune une loi de
programmation doit tout d'abord
permettre de tracer des person
respective et ce n'est pas un exercice
d'alignement de chiffres pour faire
plaisir à Bruxelles ou aux agences de
notation il y a exactement 50 ans en
1973 Pierre madens France écrivit un
petit manuel intitulé science économique
et lucidité politique démontrant que
l'économie n'est rien sans la politique
et que la politique ne saurait faire
abstraction totale des lois économique
pour aborder la multitude des paramètres
et la complexité des situations il
disait ceci à propos de la
responsabilité de l'État une action
publique éclairée continue énergique et
nécessaire quelques pages plus loin
démontrit que pour que l'action publique
soit éclairé continue et énergique il
insistait sur l'intérêt de la
planification c'est cela que sur le
c'est sur cette planification que
devrait reposer une loi de programmation
des finances publiques une planification
de l'élan que vous souhaitez donner au
pays typiquement madame la Première
ministre cette loi de programmation les
finances publiques devrait intégrer les
objectifs de transition écologique que
vous avez présenté en mai dernier vous
constaterez avec moi ce n'est pas le cas
puisque le texte que vous nous soumettez
au 49 qui est soumis au 493 et celui que
vous avez écrit en 2022 bien avant bien
avant que vous présentiez vos objectifs
pour la transition écologique
typiquement elle devrait mettre en avant
l'élan qui est à donner à notre pays
pour réaliser cette transition
écologique pour mobiliser toutes les
forces vivent pour donner une
perspective crédible et pour indiquer
son financement dès lors votre exercice
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques est un exercice abstrait fait
pour dire à Bruxelles que vous l'avez
fait ensuite une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
doit tenir compte des urgences du pays
là encore madame la Première ministre
l'objectif n'est pas rempli le groupe
des le groupe des députés socialistes et
apparentés a déposé une proposition de
contrebudget pour 2024 avec cinq
urgences avec cinq urgences cinq
urgences qui incluent entre autres aussi
une refonte de la trajectoire budgétaire
que vous avez fixée madame la Première
ministre si on jette un regard sur le
passé on observe que aucune réduction de
déficit public de 0,5 points de PIB
c'est-à-dire celle que vous inscrivez
dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques aucune ne s'est faite
en dehors d'une croissance à deux points
sauf une fois sauf une fois c'était en
2013 et ça a endommagé l'économie du
pays alors il y a deux options soit le
gouvernement ne fera pas cette
trajectoire budgétaire et dans ce cas
vous mentez à Bruxelles et au peuple
français soit vous la respectez et ça
cassera irréédiablement notre économie
pour notre part comme je l'ai indiqué
nous avons décliner cinq urgences
budgétisées et qu'il nous paraîtrait
très important de pouvoir mettre en
œuvre la première c'est Depp d'abord de
répondre à la crise du pouvoir d'achat
que connaissent nos concitoyens nous
vous avons fait plusieurs propositions
le SMIC à 1600 € la revalorisation du
repas l'instauration d'un repas cru à 1
€ pour tous les étudiants ou le blocage
des prix de première nécessité pour nos
concitoyens d'outrem la deuxième c'est
de répondre à la crise sanitaire et
sociale et historique à laquelle nous
faisons face vous le savez l'hôpital
craque il y a une désertification
médicale qui gagne le terrain la santé
mentale se dégrade les crèches ne
répondent plus aux besoins les épades
manquent de bras la réforme de retraite
est vécue comme une nouvelle injustice
la luste pourrait être encore longue
face à cette situation votre
gouvernement envisage des coupes
budgétaires dès 2024 à l'inverse nous
pensons qu'une autre voie est possible
que nous avons chiffré dans une
trajectoire budgétaire différente de la
vôtre sur la désertification médicale
nous vous avons formulé plusieurs
propositions et nous vous rappelons que
ce n'est pas parce que vous avez
supprimé le numérus closusus en 2018 en
2018 c'est-à-dire il y a 5 ans qu'il y a
plus de place pour de formation des
médecins qui ont été ouvertes c'est pour
ça que nous pensons que dès 2024 il faut
qu'il y ait 2000 places 2000 places qui
soi ouvertes en plus 2000 places qui soi
ouvertes en plus
2000 c'est pas la peine de vous fâcher
mes chers collègues ouvrir de 2000 plac
de médecin ouvrir 2000 places de
formation de médecin en plus c'est 38
million d'euros vous n'êtes même pas
capable d'inscrire 38 millions d'euros
pour former 2000 médecins de plus ça
c'est une honte c'est monsieur le
Président Maillard vous pouvez tordre
les chiffres la vérité des chiffres est
là il faut mais c'est vrai monsieur
Mayard c'est vrai vous êtes passé de
9000 à 10000 vous pouz s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence
monsieur le Président s'il vous plaît
n'miez pas les chiffres mais vous savez
ils disent la réalité de votre action
ils disent la réalité de ce que vous
votez une loi de programmation des
finances publiques doit préparer
l'avenir et répondre aux porter des
réponses concrètes à l'immense défi
climatique qui est devant nous enfin la
4ème urgence est celle du logement qui
signe véritablement votre échec nos
proposition vous les avez peut-être
entendu c'est une production de 100000
logements de privés 125000 logements
sociaux c'est-à-dire 30000 de plus
qu'aujourd'hui enfin la 5ème urgence
c'est l'éducation pour améliorer les
conditions d'apprentissage parmi les
mesures que nous proposons il y a un
effectif maximum de 19 élèves par classe
à l'école élémentaire et de 24 élèves
par classe au collège enfin une loi de
programmation et ce sera le trisème
point doit être un exercice partagé au
cours des dernières années nous avons
été amenés à voter plusieurs lois de
programmation celle sur la recherche et
l'enseignement supérieur celle sur la
justice celle sur la police et la
gendarmerie en général ces lois de
programmation sont toutes précédées
d'états généraux toutes qui permettent
de rassembler les forces vives du pays
qui permettent de confronter des
opinions qui ne sont pas les vôtres pour
les finances publiques rien de tout ceci
pire je le redis le 25 octobre 2022
l'Assemblée nationale a voté contre
votre texte je n'ignore pas que cette
configuration politique que nous
connaissons depuis juin 2022 est inédite
sous la 5e République avec une majorité
relative à qui il manque plus de 40
députés pour avoir une majorité absolue
mais la responsabilité qui est la votre
en tant que chef du gouvernement aurait
dû vous conduire à prendre acte de cette
situation inédite en imaginant de
nouvelles méthodes de travail et la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
aurait pu en être l'occasion il est pour
nous impensable que ce soit uniquement
le président de la République et vous
seul madame la Première ministre qui
décidiez sans y associer le Parlement
vous faites sans doute le Paris madame
la Première ministre qu'une majorité de
députés n'osera jamais voter la censure
ce qui vous donnerait la liberté d'agir
à votre guise sans rendre de compte en
faisant ce pari vous alimentez le
ressentiment de nos concitoyens envers
nos institutions qui constate désormaet
que la conduite de l'action publique ne
repose plus qu'entre les mains du
Président de la République et d'une
poignée de ministre sans aucun garde-fou
parlementaire je vous dis très
franchement madame la Première ministre
ce Paris est très dangereux aussi c'est
pour cette raison que que ce soir le
groupe socialiste et apparenté votera
cette motion de censure je vous
remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
François Jolivet pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les
ministres le groupe la Gauche démocrate
et républ
permet au groupe horizo et apparenté de
redire combien il juge que l'adoption
d'une loi de programmation des finances
publiques est indispensable pour notre
pays dans un article récent Olivier
Blanchard ancien économiste en chef du
Fond Monétaire International mais en
garde on ne peut plus clairement sur le
risque d'une remontée durable des taux
d'intérêt l'enjeu est clair avec des T
d'intérêt à long terme supérieur au taux
de croissance de
l'économie tout déficit public primaire
entraînera une hausse mécanique du ratio
d'entêement public sur le
PIB je constate que cet avertissement
nous vient d'un économiste qui n'a
jamais prené l'austérité ni a été un
farouche opposant à l'endettement public
puisque certains sur tous les bancs y
ont fait référence par le
passé
on ne nous accusera donc pas ici de
jouer les cassandres sans y être fondé
l'aire de l'argent gratuit est terminé
notre pays n'emprunte plus sur les
marchés à taux négatif comme cela était
encore le cas il y a quelques années
maintenant c'est 3 ou 4 % et peut-être
plus dès lors la charge de la dette
s'envole près de 75 milliards d'euros
pour l'État sur la seule année 2027
c'est autant de fin
que nous pouvons affecter au politiques
publi prioritaire qui demande des
investissements massifs au prier r
desquels la transition écologique et la
modernisation des services publics nous
devons avoir des idées claires pour
réduire progressivement mais réellement
notre déficit et ainsi contenir notre
endettement pour garantir notre
souveraineté nous devons être crédiible
et sérieux pour ne pas connaître ce que
nos voisins grecs ou italiens ont subi
durant la crise des dettes souveraines
car tout cela n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
l'histoire le dit le rétablissement des
finances publiques n'est pas un caprice
de vieux barbon de droite mais une
impérieuse nécessité pour les Français
et les générations futures c'est une
question de responsabilité et le groupe
Horizon est
responsable et cela est encore plus vrai
à la lumière de l'article d'Olivier
Blanchard que je vous citais tout à
l'heure en ce sens il nous semble que le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2023
et 2027 fixe une voie ambitieuse mais
crédible le déficit public qui
s'établira à 4,4 % du PIB en 2024 devra
refluer sous les 3 % à l'horizon 2027 et
à 2,7 % pour être précis
combiné aux prévisions de croissance et
de taux d'intérêt cela conduirait à
réduire la dette publique à 108,1 % du
PIB en 2027 contre 69,7 % cette année et
l'année prochaine la trajectoire fixée
est
d'ampuicieuse mais soutenable loin de
l'austérité que certains veulent venir
voir pour prospérer
politiquement je rappelle qu'avec une
dépense publique durable supérieur à 5 %
du PIB la France est certainement le
pays austéritaire le plus envié de la
planète la première priorité restera
donc de respecter cette trajectoire dans
les 4 ans à venir ce qui n'a jamais été
fait par le passé avant de se fixer des
objectifs dont nous savons pertinemment
qu'il ne seront jamais tenus nous
ferions mieux collectivement de chercher
à tenir une trajectoire des finances
publiques ensemble et pas pour nous mais
pour pour les générations futures un cap
clair et une boussole par avis de
tempête voici la raison première de ce
projet loi de programmation des finances
publiques j'ajouterai très rapidement
car cela a déjà est fait par de
nombreux intervenants à cette
tribune que le versement de l'Union
européenne de quelques subsides certains
en parlent de cette manière-là et bien
en fait permettra à la France de
retrouver 18 milliards d'euros nous ne
pouvons faire un choix de versement et
faire l'impasse sur ces choix européens
et comme bientôt nous aurons des
élections européennes nous verrons
celles et ceux qui feront campagne et ce
qu'ils diront à leurs électeurs je
terminerai enfin mon propos par un
rappel qui me semble salutaire alors que
les oppositions répètent à l'envie que
le recours à l'article 49 aligné 3 de la
Constitution constitue j'ouvre le
guillemets une brutalisation je les
ferme de la démocratie et un
affaiblissement du Parlement je m'étonne
je m'étonne mes chers collègues que vous
soyez opposé à une loi de
programmation car ce texte est un outil
précieux pour nous parlementaires afin
d'évaluer et de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement en ne l'adoptant pas vous
vous êche de dire que nous n'avons pas
tenu nos objectifs il prévoit notamment
la limitation dans le temps et
l'évaluation des dispositifs d'X
entreprises je m'étonne que les membres
de la nupes ne le relèvent pas enfin en
réalité je ne m'étonne presque de rien
vous nous habituez depuis un an et demi
à une opposition que je trouve trop
systématique et indigne des
banques de cette
assemblée motion de censure après motion
de censure
vousiss même sil vous plaît sans vous en
rendre compte la portée de l'acte
politique qui est le nôtre madame la
Première ministre le groupe horizon et
apparenté ne votera bien évidemment pas
cette motion de censure je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Marie
pochon pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
loi Macron le gouvernement prétend
promouvoir le débat parlementaire puis
impose le 493 bafouant la représentation
nationale Franck Riester 17 février 2015
13 13 novembre 2023 8 ans plus tard le
même Franck rester déclare par la
présente lettre sur le fondement de
l'article 493 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement madame Bor ne fait même
plus l'effort de se déplacer devant les
représent entend tous les Français pour
leur annoncer qu'elle ne tiendra pas
compte de leur vote nous y voilà donc au
17e 493 en un peu plus d'un an 17 ça en
devient ridicule de faire comme si nos
voies et celles que nous représentons
ici compt réellement pour quelque chose
dans la fabrique de la loi 17 ce n'est
même plus une représentation théâtrale
que nous jouons mais une comédie pas
bien drôle un simulacre de vie
démocratique dans la verticalité de la
5e République 17 c'est le nombre de mois
exactement que nous sommes élus ici 17
mois que comme certains de mes collègues
j'exerce mon premier mandat 17 fois que
l'on me somme de me taire voire
d'applaudir à vous voir arriver 17 je ne
sais pas s'il faut en rire ou en pleurer
17 non ça n'est pas une comédie c'est un
drame un friller dépourvu de tout
suspense hcokien un truc qui fout les
jeton un mercredi soir et vous pouvez
rire chers collègues trouve que le
spectacle est divertissant mais notez
qu'au début de ce drame le personnage
principal est mort c'est la démocratie
la démocratie qui assoit par la
République des règles simples des
valeurs des institutions et des
pratiques que vous assumez tuer peu à
peu le drame en pire chers collègues
parce qu'au 17e coup de minuit oui il y
en a beaucoup dans cette histoire et ça
ne s'arrête pas on a perdu plein de
personnages pendant que les députés
doivent déserter les rangs pour Diler 3
francs 6 sous derrière les portes closes
des ministère ce sont de nouveau je vous
l'annonce là le drame les millions de
Français portés disparus 17 heureusement
c'est aussi le numéro de la police on va
pouvoir lancer l'enquête et on espère
trouver les responsables aux urnes plus
personne la haine que vous agitez le
ressentiment l'individualisme et le
repli sur soi prennent le pas sur les
solidarités et l'espoir de vivre mieux
ce sont les victimes de ce friller que
vous pensz en H clos dans cet hémicycle
madame la Première ministre mais je suis
au regret de vous annoncer que nous
sommes filmés que des millions de gens
nous regardent qu'ils entendent parler
de ce que vous faites de ce que vous
normalisez dans nos institutions et nos
manifestations républicaines de ce que
vous banalisez dans le piétinement de la
représentation nationale tout cela nul
ne sait ce qu'il en adviendra des
millions de gens ont défilé dans les
rues pour s'opposer il y a quelques mois
à la réforme des retraites que vous avez
passé en force des millions de gens ont
voté parfois pour la première fois lors
des élections de juin 2022 parfois avec
colère parfois avec résignation parfois
avec grand espoir et ils ne le feront
plus parce que vous leur enlevez leur
voix pour des petits jeux politique des
millions de gens avaient exprimé leur
doléance lors du grand débat national il
y a exactement 5 ans dans des courriers
si sincères et si émouvants que ça
aurait fait un peu tâche dans cette
pratique du pouvoir pragmatique et
raisonnable qui est la vôtre vous avez
pré préférez les enfouir dans les
archives départementales là sont ceux
dont vous niez l'existence et que vous
refusez d'écouter madame la Première
ministre et peut-être bien que vous vous
en fichez mais ils emplissent nos
permanences nos agendas nos boîtes aux
lettres 17 17 ce sont 17 coup de trop et
vous pourrez vous dire que j'exagère
mais je peux just je peux juste vous
dire sincèrement honnêtement que ce que
vous êtes en train de faire avec
monsieur le Président de la République
avec votre majorité toute relative que
vous feriez mieux d'analyser par
ailleurs c'est bien petit pour notre
pays pour la grandeur de notre histoire
la grandeur du vivant qui l'abrite et la
grandeur des gens qui vivent et que vous
la baissez à chaque coup à un niveau où
je ne sais s'il SAA sans relev 4 ans
c'est long mais les mains tendues à
l'extrême droite les renimements de
valeurs la verticalité de toute votre
politique l'austérité pour les petits et
l'abondance pour les puissants les
polémiques des atmosphères dihadistes au
terroristes écologistes que vous
décrétez oui ce sont vos mots oui vous
mélangez tout et oui c'est dangereux le
mépris le mépris le mépris pr de tout
cela nul ne sait ce qu'il
adviendra au diable votre soi-disant
pragmatisme et votre soi-disant raison
est-ce donc la raison qui vous pousse à
entretenir une douce indifférence aux
inégalités qui se creusent à la grande
pauvreté qui explose aux enfants dormant
à la rue aux agriculteurs qui jettent
l'éponge aux travailleurs précaires aux
français tombés sous le seuil de
pauvreté en 2021 plus d'un demi million
madame la Première ministre autant que
toute la population de mon département
la Drome est-ce le pragmatisme qui vous
incite à ignorer toutes les alertes
scientifiques sur les investissements
massifs je dis bien massifs qu'il nous
faut opérer pour protéger le vivant qui
vous fait oublier alors qu'on est fin
2023 de porter une loi de programmation
des financements de la transition
écologique réclamé par tous les
scientifiques face à l'urgence de
l'effondrement écologique de notre monde
est-ce le pragmatisme ou la raison qui
dicte votre trajectoire financière que
je me permets de résumer ainsi
l'austérité pour les petits sur les
services publics l'hôpital l'école la
gendarmie la gendarmerie nos ruralité et
l'abondance pour les puissants avec 100
milliards d'euros de baisse d'impôt et
de cotisation depuis 2018 pour les
seules entreprises sans aucune
conditionnalité est-ce le pragmatisme ou
la raison qui vous conduit à l'asphixie
des collectivités locales en premier
lieu des petites communes qui vous fait
accélérer la disparition des services
publics sous couvert de France service
porté à bout de bras par les élus locaux
et les associations la promesse
républicaine partout elle s'ffrite
partout elle est délaissée tout cela nul
ne sait ce qu'il en adviendra la colère
qui s'exprime notre pays ce n'est pas un
truc très français elle a des racines
très concrètes dans l'abandon de
territoire entier dans vos logiques de
marché qui plongent les gens dans des
situations inextricables dans la perte
de sens que l'ordre l'ordre l'ordre ne
pourra combler dans des mobilisations
méprisées dans votre incapacité à
respecter vos propres engagements
écologiques madame la Première ministre
de vos actes de vos choix politiques oui
vous-même ne savez en réalité pas ce
qu'il adviendra je peux juste vous dire
qu'il aurait pu en être autrement que
que la République elle n'est jamais
acquise que c'est une conquête
permanente et qu'on pourrait faire
tellement mieux tellement mieux pour
pour en être à la hauteur car notre
République c'est la
liberté la liberté c'est de pouvoir
s'émanciper de ce que la société nous
assigne la liberté d'aller et venir de
pouvoir poursuivre le chemin que l'on
s'est choisi de pouvoir poursuivre ses
rêves qu'on viennent d'un petit village
enclavé ou d'un quartier populaire de
pouvoir aimer de pouvoir voyager
travailler ou de ne pas travailler peu
importe de pouvoir vivre dignement de
permettre à chaque enfant de la France
chaque jeune fille et chaque jeune
garçon de vivre libre notre République
madame la Première ministre c'est celle
de l'égal dignité de toutes et tous
c'est chérir ce troisème pouvoir celui
de la justice dont nous devons
sacraliser l'indépendance parce que
c'est elle qui garantit l'égalité de
chacun que vous soyez puissant ou
misérable devant la loi de la République
il y a dans notre pays des enfants qui
n'ont pas les mêmes droits que les
autres il y a dans notre pays des
citoyens qui peinent à comprendre la
promesse républicaine celle de J de Blom
de mandz France parce qu'elle ne
s'applique pas partout et pour tous de
la même manière être français c'est ne
jamais oublier ce cap de l'égalité de
tout faire pour que nos petits villages
soient revitalisés que bureau de poste
centre des impôts écoles structure
d'accès au droit au transport à la
culture à la santé soit garantie c'est
tout faire pour défendre les services
publics le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en
nont pas notre République madame la
Première ministre elle a une histoire et
cette histoire elle est profondément
sociale c'est celle de l'État providence
de la distribution de la solidarité de
l'accueil
inconditionnel on ne conçoit la grandeur
de notre République qu'au sort qu'elle
réserve au plus démunis on en conçoit la
richesse qu'à l'engagement de millions
d'hommes et de femmes particulièrement
là où l'État est le moins présent c'est
alors l'accès aux soins pour toutes et
tous la bataille pour que les Françaises
et les Français qui vivent dans un petit
village ne se voi pas retirer 2 ans
d'espérance de vie juste parce que vos
choix politique ont fermé les hôpitaux
de
proximité notre République c'est chacun
d'entre nous
elle ne se conçoit jamais de manière
verticale par la volonté d'une seule
personne elle est un commun la
République n'exclut pas elle ne réduit
pas les humains en son sein justement sa
grandeur est d'ouvrir d'émancip d'être
partagé notre République madame la
Première ministre est bousculée à une
vitesse folle j'ai grandi dans une forme
d'insouciance face à l'effondrement du
vivant et je sais que celle-ci habite là
est un autre drame encore nombreux
d'entre vous pourtant toutes et tous
nous sommes en train de traverser le
plus grand défi auquel l'humanité n'est
jamais été confronté la chute de la
biodiversité et le cataclysme
climatique madame la Première ministre
la République du 21e siècle devra être
une république écologique ou ne sera
pas c cette république là ça n'est pas
un vieux texte constitutionnel duquel on
tire des fondements pour piétiner
l'assemblement l'Assemblée nationale et
ce qui s'y exprime cette république là
c'est notre devoir que de la faire
advenir et nous sommes ici au moins 151
députés je dis bien au moins pour la
faire advenir à cette république là vos
choix tous vos choix s'y sont opposés
alors la République c'est aussi le droit
de contester l'ordre des choses quand il
est franchement dans le désordre là est
la plus grande des libertés là aussi est
le plus vertigineux de nos devoirs aussi
sur le fondement de votre indifférence
au plus vérable et de l'explosion de la
grande pauvreté sur le fondement de la
brutalité de votre politique et de votre
méthode sur le fondement de votre
capitulation écologique et parce que
vous avez fait le choix d'un peu plus
abîmer nos institutions et cette si
belle République madame la Première
ministre au nom de l'ensemble du groupe
écologiste nous engagerons notre vote
pour cette motion de
censure je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas D
ponteignan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers collègues en moins de 18
mois voici la 22e motion de censure
suite à votre 17
493 nous pensions
avoir plî mais c'était bien mal vous
connaître madame la Première ministre
puisque vous réussissez l'exploit de
déclencher ce 493 avant même le début de
la discussion générale votre loi de
programmation des finances publiques
2024-2027 est fondée sur des prévisions
de croissance et d'inflation tellement
erroné que non content de nous empêcher
de l'amender vous voulez maintenant tout
simplement nous empêcher de nous
exprimer comment allez-vous par exemple
financer la charge de la dette ça vous
fait rire qui est estimé à plus de 74
milliards d'euros en 2027 et vous riez
toujours au lieu des 60 milliards que
vous aviez calculé il y a de cela une
année seulement comment allez-vous pour
respecter cette loi de programmation
fantommatique réalisé chaque année entre
2005 et 2027 12 milliards d'économie
supplémentaire alors que vous refusez de
vous attaquer au vrais gaspillage tel
que la grande fraude fiscale notamment à
la TVA tel que la fraude massive des
fausses cartes vitales tel que le coût
aurissant de l'immigration tel que
grande réalisation du ministre de
l'économie les fameux empreints d'État à
des taux d'intérêt indexés sur
l'inflation nationale ou européenne que
vous continuez à émettre mensuellement
alors qu'ils nous ont coûté l'année
dernière 12 milliards 12 milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires comment votre
gouvernement alors qu'il peut emprunter
à taux fixe continue à emprunter à taux
variable c'est un véritable mes chers
collègues scandale d'État alors oui oui
ne pouvant détailler en 5 minutes
seulement les failles de votre loi de
programmation permettez que je me
concentre sur une dépense là aussi
ahurissante le coût exorbitant de
l'Union européenne car je vous le
rappelle chers collègues chers collègues
en raison d'un autre 493 nous avons été
privés dans cet hémicycle d'un débat
important sur la contribution annuelle
qui s'élève à près de 24 milliards
d'euros et oui la contribution nette les
Français doivent le savoir la
contribution nette de la France a été
multiplié par plus de 10 passant de 782
millions en
1994 à plus de 10 milliards en
2021 si l'on additionne les Français
doivent le savoir les contributions
netes versées depuis seulement 2012 en
10 ans seulement notre pays les Français
auront versé à l'Union européenne 74
milliards d'euros net quand on fait la
différence entre ce qu'on a versé et ce
qu'on a
reçu 74 milliards d'euros combien
d'hôpitaux fermé combien d'écoles
fermées combien d'infirmières sous-payé
combien de d'usines délocalisé par ces
subventions à nos concurrents pour
alimenter une bureaucratie bruxelloise
qui augmente ses salaires de manière
indécente
pour financer nos concurrents les
délocalisations qui sacrifient nos
territoires pour financer le sabotage de
notre système électrique énergétique et
le nouvel accord européen d'ailleurs
vous prétendez être un succès ne change
absolument rien à la fixation du prix de
l'électricité et contrairement à ce que
vous dites nous pourrions totalement
sortir du marché européen pour fixer
notre prix en fonction de nos coûts de
production tout en maintenant des
interconnexions d'approvisionnement cela
existe avec l'Angleterre qui n'est pas
dans l'Union européenne pour financer
aussi les projets libertides de l'Union
européenne pour financer comble de tout
l'élargissement de l'Union à l'Ukraine
qui selon le Financial Times va coûter
186 milliards d'euros à l'Union
européenne c'est-à-dire 32 milliards
supplémentaires à notre pays et vous
nous dites et vous nous dites qu'il faut
voter cette loi de programmation parce
qu'il faut obéir à Bruxelles obéir aussi
à ce fameux plan de relance qui est le
plus grand marché de dupe signé par
Emmanuel Macron et Bruno Le Maire censé
rapporter 37 milliards à la France il va
coûter à la fin 109 milliards à notre
pays soit un delta de 72 milliards parce
que bien sûr Bruxelles n'avait pas prévu
les taux d'intérêt qui ont été explosés
cette loi de programmation en définitive
est le symbole de votre soumission à une
Commission de Bruxelles antidémocratique
oligarchique qui détruit la France et
trahit l'idée européenne initiale il est
vital de mettre fin à vos agissements
destructeurs et de rétablir la
souveraineté de la France dans une
Europe des nations libres et des
coopérations concrètes la seule qui peut
fonctionner et avoir des résultat voilà
pourquoi vous méritez la
censure merci beaucoup la parole est à
madame la Première
[Musique]
ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez s'il vous plaît madame la Première
ministre
allez-y madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés je ne dirai qu'un mot de la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
elle a fait l'objet d'un large débat
depuis plus d'un an vous connaissez nos
positions et les Atur de la majorité ont
parfaitement rappelé pourquoi ce texte
était nécessaire pour notre pays comment
il assurer notre souveraineté comment il
ouvrait la voie à des investissements
majeurs pour la transition écologique
comment il garantissait aux Français que
nous n'augmenterons pas les impôts ce
texte c'est la responsabilité budgétaire
sans l'austérité ce cap nous y tenons et
ce soir quelques semaines à peine après
le rejet d'une première motion de s sur
ce projet de loi nous avons également eu
l'occasion d'entendre à nouveau les
positions des députés sensur entre
irresponsabilité budgétaire pour les uns
et regjet pavlovien de l'Europe pour les
autres mesdames et messieurs les députés
alors que minuit approche en ce mercredi
soir je voulais profiter de ce moment
pour partager une réflexion avec vous
les débats dans cet hémicycle et plus
encore lors de l'examen de ces motions
de censure à répétition sont trop
souvent devenus le prétexte à tous les
débordements toutes les insultes toutes
les
outrances bien sûr cette assemblée a
connu des débats vifs parfois même
violents bien sûr les idées les idées
s'y disent avec force et parfois
emportement bien sûr certains mouvements
dans lesémicycle font partie intégrante
du débat
parlementaire mais comment pouvons-nous
accepter semaine après semaine le
déferlement de violence qui remplace
trop souvent la défense des
[Applaudissements]
idées mesdames et messieurs les députés
de la France
insoumise nous avons des convictions aux
antipodes cela fait de nous des
opposants pas des ennemis pourtant à
chaque fois je suis toujours plus marqué
par la multiplication de vos injures
toujours plus até Paros vos appels à la
haine car il s'agit bien de cela quand
semaine après semaine les insultes
remplacent les conviction quand jeudi
dernier des mots comme assassin ou des
références à la guillotine se sont
multiplié à chaque fois je suis plus
effaré par votre
violence qui désin et ouvre à tous les
[Musique]
dérapages monsieur
léom
[Applaudissements]
non mais vous démontrez ce que je suis
en train de dire monsieur le député
chaque fois je suis plus sidéré par
votre suffisance vous qui prétendez
parler au nom du peuple dans son
ensemble alors que vous avez perdu
toutes les élections les unes après les
autres votre suffisance quand vous
refusez par principe de reconnaître
l'once du début d'un tort quand vous
censurez même au sein de vos rangs
toutes celles etux qui émettent des
opinions
[Applaudissements]
différentes mais surtout à chaque fois
je suis plus déterminé déterminé face à
la brutalisation de nos débats et de
notre société on dit que les élus
doivent montrer l'exemple je le crois et
si vous faites de cet hémicycle depuis
des mois le lieu où toutes les violences
verbales sont permises comment
pouvez-vous ensuite vous étonner de la
banalisation de la violence dans le
quotidien de nos concitoyens alors avec
mon gouvernement avec ma avec la
majorité nous sommes résolus à assurer
l'apaisement de notre
société je suis plus déterminé pour la
cohésion nationale quand vous refusez
par principe tous les moments d'unité
quand vous parvenez à politiser et
tenter de salir même des combats qui
devraient tous nous rassembler comme la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme
[Applaudissements]
avec mon gouvernement avec la majorité
nous sommes résolus à porter l'unité
autour des valeurs de la
République par mon histoire par mon
parcours par mes convictions je sais que
l'extrême droite est un péril grave et
je suis convaincu que face à elle un
réflexe républicain s'impose toujours
par calcul vous pensez qu'il faut agonir
le gouvernement d'injure pour paraître
les opposants les plus féroces vous avez
gagné la palme de l'outrance pas abreuv
d'opposition l'extrême droite
n'attendait que ça à chacun de vos coup
d'éclat elle semble plus raisonnable à
chacun de vos flots d'injure elle semble
plus républicaine à chacune de vos
insultes l'extrême droite gagne des
voix
alors je vous le demande d'où vous vient
l'idée que la civilité serait
incompatible avec l'opposition sans
doute d'un billet du bloc de votre
leader enfermé dans ces élucubrations
béliqueuses du fait de ces échecs
répétés dans les urnes vous fissurez la
République à D seins vous laissez croire
que la violence verbale débridée est le
seul mode de
débat alors je suis
lucide je sais que ne vous changera pas
ne serait-ce qu'écouter quelqu'un qui ne
pense pas comme vous vous êtes
insupportable c'est pourtant le principe
même de la démocratie il n'est pas
question de renoncer à nos convictions
pas question d'adoucir nos positions au
fond il n'est question que d'une chose
montrer qu'en démocratie montrer qu'en
République on peut être en désaccord et
pourtant se respecter je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre la discussion est
close je vais mettre voit la motion de
censure déposée par Monsieur André
chassen madame matine pano cyiel châelin
et s membbres de l'Assemblée le scrutin
est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale je rappelle que
seul les députés favorables à la motion
de censure participent au scrutin et que
le vote se déroule dans les salles
voisines de l'hémicycle le scrutin va
être ouvert pour 20 minutes il sera donc
clos à
23h30 la séance est
suspendu voici les résultats du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 143 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée en
conséquence le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023-2027 est considéré
comme adopté en lecture définitive